[Musique]
mes chers compatriotes
permettez moi juste de vous dire que ce
soir je ne suis pas le premier ministre
si vous n'êtes pas le président de la
république le 10 mai chacun devra voter
selon sa conscience
vous m'avez élu en mai dernier pour que
nous construisions ensemble une nouvelle
france
oui un homme politique monsieur leroy ne
démissionne pas je viens de remettre la
démission de mon gouvernement au
président de la république
je crois qu'un homme politique ne doit
pas lâcher tout eh bien je voudrais dire
au premier ministre et à monsieur
mitterrand qu'on ne construit pas la
grandeur de la france avec de l'eau
tiède et du chloroforme
ce que nous voulons aujourd'hui c'est
lutter efficacement contre le terrorisme
contre la criminalité contre la
délinquance et croyez bien s'en porter
la moindre atteinte ça va de soi aux
droits de l'homme ce que j'ai la tête de
quelqu'un qui veut porter atteinte aux
droits de l'homme
le petit noir que vous prenez sur votre
comptoir suppose matin tout le monde pas
de malentendu il s'agit de la tasse il
s'agit de la taxe
monsieur chirac vous êtes avec nous en
direct mais j'ai l'impression qu'il
n'entend pas monsieur chirac
qu'est ce qui lui arrive à la deuxième
chaîne non non c'est chirac est ce que
vous aviez un ours quand vous étiez
petit j'avais un lapin faux clash quand
je vais au resto on ne demande même pas
ce que je vois on m'a même tout de suite
une bouteille de bière
j'aime beaucoup les pas des mangeurs de
pommes
à oui il arrive un moment où un
gouvernement ne sait plus très bien où
il en est ni ce qu'il fait ou les choses
nous échappent et où il est conduit au
total pour éviter de faire des erreurs
au fond à ne plus rien faire
l'équipe de france et la coupe de fond
la côte vous pendant entassés une
famille avec un père de famille trois ou
quatre épouses et une vingtaine de
gosses et qui gagne 50 mille francs de
prestations sociales sont naturellement
travailler il ya peu de choses qui me
font vraiment souffrir dans la vie l'une
de celles qui me font souffrir c'est le
bruit des tronçonneuses
je ne peux pas supporter le bruit des
tronçonneuses si vous ajoutez à cela le
bruit et l'odeur est bien le travailleur
français sur le palier deviens fou comme
problèmes provoqués
eh bien je ne suis pas disposé je vous
le dis tout de suite à subir le
terrorisme intellectuel venue d'une
gauche que je considère comme moralement
et intellectuellement décadent je
souhaite que chacun se reprennent tout
le monde ya intérêt je décide et il
exécute notre maison brûle et
nous regardons ailleurs et j'ai
d'ailleurs indiqué que dans trois ans
j'irai me baigner dans la seine devant
témoins pour montrer que la scène est
devenue les fleuves propres vive la
république et vive la france
[Musique]